>>Student: The solar panels
would kind of be spread
out between the west,
the east and the south.
>>Teacher: What's that
gonna do to the aesthetics,
to the look of your
dome, these big panels?
>>Student: Well, can I show
you something on the computer?
>>Absolutely.
>>Narrator: For the
past several years,
students in Eeva Reeder's
geometry class
at Mountlake Terrace High School
have faced a severe challenge
at the end of the school year.
>>Just like an open, inviting area.
>>Eeva: My students are engaged
in a five, six week project.
It's a culminating project
in a regular geometry class.
They bring together everything
they've learned in the geometry class
and they're applying it to
solve a real world problem.
And the problem that they have to
solve is, how do you design a state
of the art high school in the year
twenty fifty on a particular site,
and this is the site for this year.
>>So you're gonna leave
the hills as they are?
>>Yeah.
>>What are you gonna use them for?
>>All: Cross country.
>>Eeva: Oh, so you're just gonna
have a bunch of paths through here?
>>All: Yes.
>>Nice.
>>Eeva: Students are in teams
of three to four and they're
in a design competition
for a contract to build it.
>>Student: Thirty-five
by thirty-five feet long.
The back wall is twenty feet
tall, with two ten foot pillars.
>>Narrator: At the end of the
project, each team is required
to submit a site plan
for their school.
>>This actual area right here
has five buildings that act as--
>>Narrator: A scale model
of at least one room...
>>That the front row desk will
lower down into the ground--
>>Narrator: A floor plan, and a
cost estimate for construction.
>>Our total cost was eighty six
million, four hundred twenty thousand
and a hundred and twenty-two dollars.
>>Narrator: Teams submit
a written proposal
and give a final oral
presentation to a team of architects
who volunteer their time to judge
the relative merits of the proposals.
>>Eeva: Football field, a
hundred yards, three hundred feet?
>>Hundred yards, three--
>>Narrator: Reeder created this
rigorous project when she realized
that her students weren't able
to apply what they
were studying in class.
>>Eeva: It became immediately
apparent to me as a teacher
that talking to kids didn't cause
them to really deeply learn concepts,
and they might learn
the material, learn it,
so that they could spit
back formulas and so on,
on a paper and pencil test.
But they weren't able to apply
it in a context that was outside
of that unit and outside of
that worksheet or book page.
>>Why not have the whole side, this
wall be glass facing the water?
>>Eeva: It's when they can
use what they learn in class
to solve a problem that I know
that they've learned the material.
>>We'd have doors leading to
the outside classroom, so--
>>Narrator: While students must draw
on their knowledge of everything
from math and English, to
the aesthetics of design,
they also learn an
invaluable lesson in teamwork?
>>Joe: We'll see how many we can
fit, we'll see how many we can fit.
>>I'm thinking because--
>>Joe: When we finally started
on the site model there was
constant little squabbling about,
"Oh, this should go there."
>>Student: Just the bottom row itself
just holds twelve hundred people,
right?
>>Joe: No, no, no, this entire
thing holds twelve hundred people.
>>Student: Oh, the entire school.
>>Eeva: They're faced with
this really complex problem
that has certain constraints and
they have to figure out how to begin
to make the decisions and move the
process forward, and how do you do
that decision making within a group?
These are the things that are really
maybe the most powerful learnings
that come from it.
The real life, problem solving,
communication collaboration skills.
>>Joe: I did learn how
to work with people
that didn't think the way I did,
thought nonlinear, didn't believe
in deadlines sort of thing.
They really think out of the
box, which is not like me.
I'm a completely in
the box kinda person.
You gotta make sure
you work together.
>>Man: You might be able
to just kinda quickly
build a little model of it.
>>Narrator: Seattle architects,
Mark Miller and Kirk Wise,
have played a key role in the design
project for the last eight years,
acting as mentors, coaches,
and ultimately judges
of the students' work.
>>There's also escalators--
>>Eeva: A hugely important piece
of a really effective project is
to have the audience for the
student work be someone outside
of the classroom.
So I go out into the community
and I find someone who's
willing to look at their work.
>>Man: Which means that you
use the sunlight for daylight.
>>Eeva: The quality of student work
really does go through the ceiling
because they care about
these architects' opinions.
>>Man: And so these are great ideas.
You're sort of dissolving
the concept of a wall,
dissolving this idea
of indoor, outdoor.
>>Shaun: It felt so good
to do it and to present it
to like architects really boosted up
the confidence, and I really wanted
to put an impact on them,
and show 'em all I got.
>>Girls: Hi, we're max.
We'll take you to the max-imum.
>>Girl: In the beginning,
we decided to start
with the floor plans and the designs.
Our school has one main building with
four buildings onto the side of it
where it's connecting with walkways.
Can you guys imagine what it'd
be like just walking into a room
and all you see is just three
feet of wall with brick,
and then the rest windows,
even on top of you.
That's what we have in
our model right here.
>>Student: The classroom
is built down twenty feet,
so the back wall is
into the hill itself.
The rest of the walls
are made of glass.
The two side walls are
clear so you can look out
and have no disruption
with your view.
The silver pad is a light projection
and the little white
square is a three hundred
and sixty degree hologram.
This hologram is your teacher.
This hologram teacher can
change for your subject,
if you want math, you
can get Miss Reeder.
If you want physics,
you can get Einstein.
It's all programmed in.
>>Student: Education in the year
two thousand fifty is very different
from the way it was at the
beginning of the century.
Class sizes are smaller,
school budgets are much larger,
and most importantly, students
are taught differently.
Education, it has become
project based.
>>Narrator: Spending six weeks
on a single project at the end
of the school year is a bold
teaching strategy, but for Reeder
and her students, the
gamble pays off.
>>Eeva: My colleagues ask me,
how do I possibly find time
for project based learning when
there are so many concepts to cover,
so much curriculum to
cover and the pressure
to get students ready
for high stakes tests?
And my answer to them is that applied
learning, or project based learning,
is the most effective way
to deliver information
and it's the most effective way for
students to understand concepts.
Once they have learned a skill
by having to use it, it's theirs.
You don't need to cram
for it on the test.
It's a way of learning
information that works.
>>Hey, you guys, everybody wants
to direct their attention that way.
>>Yes, Whoa.
>>You will see the Rainier Tower.
>>Narrator: On the final day of
the class architecture project,
Eeva Reeder's students went on
a field trip to check out some
of Seattle's landmark structures.
>>The center of gravity for that
building is a giant concrete base
below the building.
>>Narrator: But the most
eagerly anticipated stop
on the trip was a visit to the
architectural firm of Wise Miller.
>>Man: Good morning,
glad you could make it.
>>Man: These are sketches that
we did for the high school.
You can see the light--
>>Narrator: The students were
eager to learn about the work
of these two prominent
Seattle architects,
but they were also anxious to find
out what grades they were going
to get from them on this,
the final day of assessment.
>>Man: And then they had the library
rotating and they made a point
of saying that it needed
to be larger.
>>Narrator: The architects'
judgment counts for forty percent
of a student's final
grade for the project.
It's just part of the
sophisticated rubric
that Reeder has refined
over the years.
>>Eeva: I have to come up with ways
to assess those products
and performances.
So I look at the site plan and
look at the perspective drawing.
I read the proposal and I
have a scoring guide developed
for each one of those.
But I think that the most powerful
assessment for this project is
that provided by the architects.
>>Man: And again, you will remember
this activity your whole lives
and it will make a difference.
What you've done is
very good and we want
to recognize the best of the best.
>>Narrator: With the moment of
truth at hand, students were able
to taste the thrill of winning,
or the agony of losing a contract.
>>Man: We have three groups
that we wanna recognize, ADP,
SK and Max, if you'd come up.
>>Narrator: This was also a time to
celebrate the diverse inspirations
and surprising talents that emerge
during the course of the project.
>>Man: You had a level of comfort
as you presented your work,
and when you know your work,
and you know what you're saying,
and you believe it, it comes through.
And so we wanted your building,
because you were doing a good
job in your presentation.
We're ready for best architecture.
Best architecture category
goes to Yin Yang.
Your architectural solution was
just very-- it's almost animate.
You used that word--
>>Eeva: Hearing the
architects, they said like,
"Now this is a building I'd like
to work together with you on."
You can't duplicate that
experience in a classroom.
>>Man: But we really like those
arms that reached down the hillside,
and we could see the classroom
learning going indoor and outdoor.
>>Eeva: It's so powerful for the
students because they have someone
who can deeply appreciate what
it is they've struggled with
and gone through, and someone
who can just really let them know
what a fabulous job they've done.
>>Man: Are we ready for the final?
Best overall project for this
year, I have to tell you,
that the winner was won by one point.
The winner this year goes to SK.
Come on up.
>>Eeva: To hear someone honoring
their ideas, that gives me chills.
>>Man: And their presentation
was very strong.
Their educational concept
was just wonderful.
>>Eeva: All of the little details of
the hassle of arranging field trips
and making all this come together,
it's just completely worth it.
>>Narrator: For more
information on what works
in public education,
go to Edutopia.org